even with that situation again that was
like my first full-on relationship
because where obviously I am also
religious like I do believe in God yeah
and I and I believe fornication is a sin
so with me if it's a big thing for me to
even try fornicate I rather not
um in that first relationship I was
staying with him because my intention
was marriage and we were planning to get
married right and it was a lot more
secure yeah
wouldn't it be more secure in the second
because you are married well no that's
what I mean so the second one it
happened Okay the reason why I'm not
leave is because
he's it's not that he's he's uh he's not
a uh he's a good and or amazing guy it's
more it was a it's the right person
wrong time so why how do you know it's
going to work in three years time why
the three years because it sounds like
you've got it all figured out now that
you know what a great guy he is and if
you both need to work on it sounds like
a backup plan yeah because why the three
years I don't think I don't think it's I
don't think he's an amazing guy I think
with time he will also it I feel like we
need time to figure ourselves out and
when I say that I mean I feel like he's
not ready to I feel like man a man's
under a lot of pressure he feels like he
has to have X amount of money he needs
to make sure he can keep a woman because
I feel like men feel like women will
cheat on them if they're not doing
certain things and I think he feels like
if he doesn't provide me with a million
roses and all of that I'm not going to
stay loyal to him he doesn't realize
that I'm a religious person that's not
going to be a problem if that makes
sense I just think that you need to get
it sooner or later another conversation
you can both work it out together and
grow together rather than three years
time you could you you can both be in
separate places in three years yeah you
might as well do it together you know
what you want you sound like you know
what you want you sound quite sensible
and reasonable so why not do it now and
see where you both are in three years
rather than wait for years as to jump in
because there's a lot that can happen in
for you well you can get there together
you know he's not there yet you know
what he needs and you can be there to
support him I think that's such I'm so
sorry I think there's certain things
that you need to work I get where you're
coming from I think this because you
guys got married when you were younger I
think there's certain things where you
have to work on by yourself to then be
able to come together with someone so I
get the three years thing because
clearly you've got stuff that you want
to work on and growing whatever and he's
got his own issues and I think if you
guys get back you you guys get back
together
that precious we're going to be there
because you haven't worked on your
individual selves that's why I always
say even with marriages and because I
decide to get married and stuff but I
know that I'm not ready to get married
now because the stuff that I need to
figure out and these are things I need
to figure out by myself before I can
then come together to figure out that to
figure that that part of my life out to
get me yeah okay I still think you
should want to go Carnival that's right
I want to hear that you're figuring
yourself out they just think you're
sleeping yeah
and honestly that's what it sounds like
because I don't understand what do you
no it's not that can I ask you can I ask
you how how long it's been since you
both separated like how long have you
been figuring it out
um I'll say it was the start of the
pandemic but it's not that we're
figuring it out I think it was just that
we were two different people coming
together and the pressures of the
pandemic obviously put a lot more strain
on us and I feel like also this concept
like for example
we people believe that if you're married
you have to sleep in the same bed every
single night whereas some people's
relationships aren't like that I didn't
understand that when I was younger that
actually some people genuinely don't
want to be in a bed with someone else
every single night and that's something
that I'm only coming to terms with now
if that makes sense so I think more the
more that I'm growing as a person I'm
learning a lot about myself and I'm
accepting as well that you don't have to
have what social media show as a
traditional marriage you can have your
own version yeah can I ask you a
question though do you think you and
your partner have the same core values
yes and I think that's the only reason
why we're I can see me being compatible
with him because so what's like the real
like I don't understand what what's not
there then it seems like he's a great
guy yeah no I think I think no no I
think it's not that he's a great guy
it's I've made a choice and I feel like
I will do whatever I can to make sure it
works okay if that makes sense because I
think especially with marriage it's a
big commitment and you know you do it
through thick and thin yeah um I think
it's more
um I didn't understand like when he did
mention if he did mention multiple
partners or having other partners for me
that was like what do you mean but I
then had to like recheck myself and
actually say that's not something I'm
not used to or I'm abnormal or that
isn't the norm
um so I think when I initially reacted
and again that was the trauma from the
first relationship coming through that I
had to unlearn it was almost like oh
that means you must be cheating every
day when actually he wasn't so it made
us very toxic for no reason so it kind
of goes back to like women can't handle
the truth well I've separated and like
revisiting what I actually want in life
and how it impacts me I've realized that
actually it's not I can't handle the to
mature if that makes sense then I
wouldn't be able to but as I've now
learned a lot more about myself I'm like
yeah have you had help for your trauma I
guess it was more professional help yeah
well I've done I've done counseling it's
not uh I would yeah I've done counseling
and stuff I don't think I think it's
just time so sometimes you don't even
cancel doesn't help it's just just
maturity I think it's more reason about
emotional management yeah in your
emotions
um in line with what's going on because
often we we have emotional responses to
things that are happening at that time
yeah we've thought about them we've
we've and I'm and I know someone's gonna
say oh you're mad you're saying we're no
we think about things that could happen
we think about those things think about
it and the moment we're confronted with
the situation that had we respond to the
because of your background I think
you're quite sensible in it but what I
would say is that for most women the way
you're handling it wouldn't be good
advice because for most women taking
time away and pushing it to the Future
just means racking up bodies racking up
more trauma and expecting a guy to come
and take hold of it in the in in the
future and I think that's where like
obviously like my faith comes in if that
makes sense because obviously that's
what will keep me in check in that sense
because I I don't believe in sort of
committing fornication like that to me
it protects me a bit more from that
um obviously women who might not share
my same background might be a bit yeah
maybe they might you know because yeah
them hidden is is taking more Willy yeah
but but are you actually this is the
question I would ask is are you actually
dealing with the issues at hand because
so so you're working on them separately
but you're not working on them together
and that issue so when you come back
you're going to be a different woman and
he's going to be a different man and
then there's going to be other issues
because you're not working together so I
think what's happening is I'm growing
into who I am and he's growing into who
he is and if it matches this is why I
say I give it time because if it is that
we work out we work out if not we're
just getting better at just say like
because I've got a five year old we're
getting better at co-parenting yeah I
mean so we've got it we're we're getting
better in our relationships what's the
separation his choice or yours
it was
I guess are both come on someone someone
started the conversation it wasn't who
started this way it wasn't a nice
separation yeah it was very it was a
very
um abrupt and sort of not great yeah but
who who started the like someone it's
dishonest to say that it was a mutual
thing
like someone has to start the
conversation
um someone else to say this isn't moving
out or I'm moving out or we're
this isn't working let's take some time
I guess the guy would he would say it
more than I would but then it's
it's more because I would uh yeah I
guess he would say it so you see it as
that I can't take it so yeah so it's his
choice yeah okay yeah that's abnormal
usually it's like the other way around
yeah no no I guess it was his choice but
it's more I think um obviously where we
had a child involved it was a lot harder
um because we couldn't get the right
grieving or time apart that we would
have had to because it's almost like we
had an argument the day before and then
because of my daughter we'll have to now
stay in communication
um I think the time the covert time
really helped sort of put that aside do
you think like if you called him
tomorrow and said like I want to work
this out let's move back in together he
would do it not yet not yet I think and
he's also agreed in a few years
potentially it's more likely whereas I
think he isn't where he wants to be and
he knows that I'm not where I want to be
and I think one of the biggest things
because when we did break up I never had
a hot girl summer let's say like I've
never experienced that I came from a
culture where we didn't really go about
the house I'm not trying to be rude yeah
but didn't you just say you're at
carnival before
so I never really experienced and I've
experienced that sort of dating or
casual dating or even like you know so
when I first came out of the Pan um the
relationship I was like okay yeah let me
explore this I tried it online yeah I
tried online dating it was horrendous I
tried you know
meeting people in my life it was it was
a joke so yeah like I now get to go
Carnival as a single person I guess with
my friends but again it's not it's just
for fun for me it's nothing like nothing
there's no guys
it's not serious for you but if you're
looking at it from a male perspective
these are all the flags that say okay
she doesn't want to do this no but it's
not I don't go Carnival too
it's inevitable like even if you try not
to you could be standing a guy once yeah
standby is inevitable because it's you
know when you're in a relationship and
there's things that is you know you're
me well okay let me put it like this as
from a male specific perspective and I'm
not a male but look at it like this
you're making yourself available for men
to uh and it's kind of like your words
really aren't matching what you're
saying because like you said you're a
traditional woman traditional women
don't go to Carnival no this is I'm
saying I'm saying like let me let me put
it like my mom my grandma wouldn't be
caught dead at carnival they said they
want Vibes they're like what are you
talking about